-Welcome back to "Late Night,"
everybody.
Here with the cast of "Nope."
It is so great to have you guys.
So, Jupiter's Claim
is the fictional theme park
in this film...
-Whoo!
-...that is now being
re-created.
They've actually rebuilt it
at Universal Studios,
open to the public tomorrow.
-So, yes, this --
I'm very proud of this.
Look, listen to this.
This is the first time
that a back --
Universal Studios California
backlot tour has had the --
the set at the same time
as the movie's being released.
It just goes to show you how
much they believe in this film.
And it is. It's the --
It's the theme park
that Steven Yeun's character
owns in the film.
And let's just say it's --
it's the -- the site of some --
some uncanny weirdness...
[ Laughter ]
...and also, some --
some horrible, horrible things.
[ Laughter ]
But it's cheery, and it's happy.
-Makes me very happy.
Jordan, we've talked in the past
when you were on.
We've known each other
for over 20 years.
We've gone to some amusement
parks together over the years.
-We have. Well, it's very --
it is very funny.
We're here pretending like
we haven't been, like,
inebriated on 20 different
substances...
-Yeah, exactly.
[ Laughter ]
-...in a Dutch theme park...
-Yeah.
-...like, sweating over
the bust of, like, a --
of a fantasy Dutch guy.
-Yeah, we've had --
We should probably leave it
at that, but we had some...
[ Laughter ]
We had some -- yeah.
-I wanted more.
-Yeah.
-It was all legal substances.
-I'm sorry
to play Daniel's mom here,
but I think there's some things
we're not supposed to talk about
on television.
[ Laughter ]
-So good, man.
So good.
-Now, do you -- are you someone
who likes theme parks?
-Oh, my gosh.
I love theme parks.
And I was so excited.
Like he's saying,
this is the first time
it's ever happened before,
so I was like -- I remember,
I kept asking Jordan,
I said, "Is it gonna leave?"
He's like,
"Nope, it's here to stay."
I'm like, "It's forever?"
[ Laughter ]
We start playing games.
I got to do --
I mean, I had my Jupe jingle.
You rocking a little bit
of the merch, Lil Key --
You know what I mean?
You want to show them?
-Oh, this -- This is just
a reference to one of
my favorite movies from
the '90s, "Kid Sheriff."
-Which one?
-"Kid Sheriff."
-Oh, "kid Sheriff."
There you go.
Yeah, great -- a great film.
-Yeah, which is --
which, of course, Jupe's Claim
is loosely based off of.
-Yeah, yeah. there you go.
You got to take your dad,
Brandon, to this part of the
park before it opened, right?
-Yeah.
It's -- It's insane,
because my dad
came to California.
I've lived there for 11 years,
and he's never been able
to make it out until now
for the premiere of the film.
And he was like,
"Oh, I've always wanted to go
to Universal.
I'm gonna buy a ticket."
I was like, "No, no! I just
did a movie with them, man!"
And I was able to get us, like,
the V.I.P. tour,
and it was incredible and, like,
this is crazy to me.
Like, my life is insane.
V.I.P. tour of Universal.
Jordan Peele is next to me.
Keke Palmer, Daniel Kaluuya.
I'm on "Late Night
with Seth Meyers."
Like, bruh...
[ Cheers and applause ]
God bless, man.
This is insane to me, man.
I'm like -- just like,
"What is going on?"
-The previous younger kid
to go pro, that was his peak.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-You just raced by him.
That's, like, a footnote
on your bio now.
-Cheers man, cheers.
-You --
Do you also -- What about you?
Roller coasters?
You like any of that?
-Eh.
-Okay.
-Stress.
-What about haunted houses?
-Oh, yeah, no.
I don't like those.
[ Laughter ]
But we -- but me and my boys,
we got kicked out of one.
We got kicked out of one.
-How old were you when you got
kicked out of a haunted house?
-26.
[ Laughter ]
-Well, that's their fault
for letting you in.
-The actors --
The actors were starting --
they tried touching us.
-Man, no.
-Okay.
-So one of -- one of them
threw a punch, and then,
they said we're banned.
-Wait. So one of your friends
threw a punch?
-Yeah, one of my friends did.
Finally were like, "Aah!"
They were like --
and they were like, "Leave."
And the actors --
the actors broke character.
And I was like,
"What are you doing?
You're supposed to commit."
Like --
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
In real life,
when you punch a mummy,
they're not like, "Get out!"
[ Laughter ]
-Anybody -- Anybody anywhere
that jumps out and surprises you
has to be ready to be caught
with a punch at any moment.
It's just a risk you're taking.
-I don't -- you know what?
I'm sorry to jump in defense
of the haunted-house staff,
but I think they might assume
that you know
that's gonna happen.
-You're right.
[ Laughter ]
You're right.
-But we believe --
We're believing
in their depiction.
-Are you saying
that you were doing
a performance as good as theirs?
-Yes! I'm matching the energy
that they're giving me.
I'm like, "Oh, ay!"
[ Laughter and applause ]
-It's immersive.
He's truly immersive.
-Very, very meta.
-Yeah.
Well, I remember we --
we went once had dinner here
at one of those theme
restaurants, you know,
the sort of, like,
horror-themed.
-Yes.
-And I have great respect
for people who -- who in those
situations really sell it,
like, actors who is put
their all into it.
-Yes, we were at
the "Jekyll and Hyde."
-Yeah.
-And this was at a period
15 years ago,
where I was writing
my first script
for you to star in.
-Yeah. And I'm sorry
I turned you down.
-You said no?
-I didn't say no.
-It was not that.
-Yeah.
-I didn't finish the script,
and you were very successful.
-What was it about?
-He told me it was either
me or you for "Get Out."
[ Laughter ]
Originally,
it was called "Get In."
-He said,
"If Kaluuya says no..."
I think -- I don't think it
would have worked with me.
-Do you -- would you...
[ Laughter ]
...would you be...
Yeah, I mean, I would definitely
consider a sequel to "Get Out."
-Yeah.
-If you would consider.
-It is -- but it is very funny.
Again, I was -- I was saying
this to your cast backstage.
But we -- you know, to echo
what I said earlier, you know,
a lot of the things we did,
we were improvising together
in Amsterdam, we used to go to
horror movies all the time.
-Yes.
-A large group of us.
And now, you know, we can't
believe that one of the things
we all get to do together now
is go see Jordan's new movie.
It is -- It is an incredible
thing to take.
And you have a great eye
for talent, my friend.
-Can I ask a question?
-Yeah.
-Did you know --
Did you know that he was gonna
direct horrors and be into that?
-I knew he would be
incredibly successful,
but I would have predicted
"Key & Peele"
before I would've
predicted this. Right?
When "Key & Peele" happened,
I was like, "Of course."
-Yeah, yeah.
-But, yeah, I mean, this --
I think no one could have
predicted this.
-Jordan, I just live
for you, man.
-Like, I -- well, hey.
[ Laughter and applause ]
And I'm --
-You're the best, dude.
-This is it.
It all worked out.
-It's called "Nope."
It's called "Nope."
It's in theaters.
Oh, and this is really exciting,
you guys.
"Nope" opens in theaters
and IMAX tomorrow,
and courtesy of our friends
at IMAX --
I've got a card right here --
everyone here in the audience
is getting two tickets
to see "Nope" in IMAX.
[ Cheers and applause ]
How about that?
They're all in it.
He directed it.
Don't miss it.
It's great.
We'll be right back.
Even if you're an alien,
we'll be right back
with more "Late Night."